la gendarmerie nationale des yvelines
rassemblés dans la cour de la préfecture
une cérémonie de passation de
commandement le groupement départemental
connaît son nouveau commandant le
colonel sylvain tortelier commandé dans
ce magnifique département des yvelines
avec autant de vitres diversité autant
de problématiques
ça rend le challenge est défi d'autant
plus intéressant c'est de par le contact
avec la population les élus et les
grands représentants que nous pouvons
donc mieux finalement sentir le pouls de
ce département et donc a fortiori
répondre aux attentes de la population
après des fonctions opérationnelles à
annecy à porto vecchio il occupe aussi
des postes interministériel et au sein
de l'état major de la gendarmerie
nationale il vient remplacer le colonel
loïc barras commandant du groupement des
yvelines depuis trois ans ses qualités
sont d'abord l'inventivité la pertinence
et un extrême agilité intellectuelle qui
l'a mise en avant et sur laquelle il
s'est appuyé justement pour comprendre
les enjeux analyser les situations et
proposer toujours des solutions
intelligentes pertinentes et réaliste le
colonel loïc barras va de son côté
occupé des fonctions au sein de la
direction générale de la gendarmerie
nationale à issy les moulineaux
[Musique]